so you can actually cause the the phase
behavior of a material to change by
changing a pressure now what is pressure
so pressure of course is the effect of
the gas that is around us that is
squeezing on ourselves all the time so
we get so used to it we don't even feel
it but actually the pressure of the air
around us is pretty high it's right and
what called one atmosphere of pressure
and it's essentially a force that's
squeezing on us all the time that our
bodies are squeezing out at now you know
from either experience or not that if
you climb a very high mountain the
amount of air that is around you
decreases so let me show you what the
phase behavior of water looks like as a
function of pressure so here's the phase
diagram that I showed you before at zero
degrees Celsius water transitions from a
liquid to a solid and at 100 degrees
Celsius water transitions from a liquid
to a gas
if we increase the pressure to about one
and a half atmospheres it turns out that
the solid liquid transition still occurs
at around zero degrees Celsius it
doesn't change very much but the liquid
gas transition occurs at a higher
temperature it's at about a hundred and
twelve degrees Celsius whereas in turn
if we lower the pressure so if we went
down to about say 3/4 of an atmosphere
then again the the liquid solid
temperature stays about the same but the
liquid gas transition temperature
decreases to about 92 degrees Celsius
scientists like to organize this in what
we call a two dimensional phase diagram
so this is a phase diagram where on the
x axis we have the temperature and on
the y axis we have the pressure and what
we do is we label the locus of points
where the material changes from a solid
to a liquid to a gas by simply
connecting the dots of the lines that
we've just drawn before and this is
something that we call a phase diagram
so this is a two-dimensional phase
diagram and you see in this phase
diagram that there is a region there's a
big region where the material is a solid
there's another region where the
material is a liquid and there's a third
region where the material is a gas at
any point that you are on the phase
diagram so you can always find out what
the what the behavior of the material is
so you know at one atmosphere and about
23 degrees Celsius you can read off this
plot that water is
but this allows you to generalize it to
much other to many other conditions and
so nitrogen has a phase diagram that
you'll see looks a lot like that of
water and there's a solid phase or
liquid phase in a gas phase at low
enough pressure is actually nitrogen
also has a situation where the solid
phase transitions directly to a gas
without a liquid phase and but there's
this big liquid phase which is you know
the part at one atmosphere that gives
rise to liquid nitrogen if we change the
pressure we can change the phase of the
liquid nitrogen by cooling it I'm going
to use this vacuum system and as it
evaporates the heat goes off with the
gas and the liquid that's left behind
gets colder and colder and at some point
we're going to get below the melting
temperature of nitrogen and hopefully we
will see solid nitrogen and I'm going to
do this first I'm going to turn on the
pump and then
quickly
so the nitrogen is boiling now because
the pressure over it is lower than its
vapor pressure it's its internal wound
its internal heat that's causing it to
boil
it boils it cools and then what we see
is solid nitrogen here is dry ice if we
raise the pressure we can put the dry
ice we can put the carbon dioxide in a
place where it can exist as a liquid
going to seal it up so that the gas
cannot escape because the gas can't
escape the pressure inside of the tube
is going to go up when the pressure
inside of the tube reaches about 5
atmospheres the driest reaches a point
where instead of going directly to gas
subliming it can melt it can turn from a
solid to a liquid now what's going on
right now is heat going into the tube is
causing the dries to sublime as the gas
builds up inside of the tube the
pressure goes up and as the pressure
goes up there it goes the dry ice now
can melt now we have mostly liquid and
if I release the pressure the the liquid
carbon dioxide can no longer exist as a
liquid and because it's still cold it
condenses straight back into a solid